il avait été pris d'une telle angoisse
que la seule façon de sortir de cette
fameuse angoisse c'était de procéder à
des aveux il va expliquer que il est le
complice de Laetitia Monnier dans son
idée de cambriolage ou en tout cas de de
vol par ruse donc pendant qu'elle est
dans la baignoire avec Jean-Jacques
Lepage son boulot à lui c'était de
cambrioler en fait la maison et les
choses se sont mal passées donc ils
reconnaît le meurtre il reconnaît
également l'incendie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Plougonvelin petit village du Finistère
à la caserne des pompiers tout est calme
jusqu'à ce coup de téléphone à 5 heures
du matin
j'ai vu sa fenêtre de chambre qui est
ouverte et allumée en grand et ça c'est
quelque chose qui a pris feu sur moi
vous voyez de la fumée qui se dégage de
chez lui
ça dégageait beaucoup tout à l'heure
mais maintenant il y en a plus d'accord
mais vous voyez pas de flamme rien du
tout euh non mais je vous dis j'ai je
pense que j'en avais vu dans sa chambre
justement qu'il y a une grande fenêtre
il y a personne qui
peut bah il faudrait que j'appelle
l'autre voisin si on déclenche
tous les non c'est fermé chez lui bon
bah allez il a étonné de la cuisine
maintenant ouais enfin là si vous voulez
s'il y a eu quelque chose mais que
Monsieur depuis a éteint les lumières
s'il est dedans ça se trouve c'est lui
s'il y a de la fumée qui se dégage ou
quoi bah à ce moment-là vous nous
appelez mais là pour l'instant on va pas
engager ce cours
[Musique]
cet appel à tout d'une fausse alerte au
feu le pompier de permanence ce soir là
en a la conviction
mais il va être le point de départ d'une
incroyable histoire criminelle
[Musique]
j'étais un milieu de
savoir que c'était une histoire aussi
sordide qui allait me tomber dessus
pourquoi voulez-vous qu'elle le tue
comme ça
[Musique]
c'est quelqu'un qui avait un souci de
séduction qu'il avait l'intention de la
demander en mariage
je me sentais souillée j'en avais assez
je voulais que ça se termine
[Musique]
ce 24 juillet 2009 il est 9h lorsque de
nouveau le téléphone sonne à la caserne
des pompiers de Plougonvelin
cette fois c'est un riverain qui signale
un incendie toujours dans la même maison
évidemment les pompiers vont intervenir
immédiatement mais quand ils arrivent
c'est un véritable brasier
[Musique]
et c'est au deuxième étage de la bâtisse
qu'ils vont découvrir un cadavre d'un
homme qui est entièrement brûlé dans une
pièce qui semble être une chambre
cet homme est très vite identifié il
s'agit de Jean-Jacques Lepage le
propriétaire de la maison
la presse s'empare alors de la faire car
tout le monde se demande pourquoi les
pompiers ne sont pas intervenus plus tôt
en Bretagne deux pompiers entendus après
la mort d'un homme dans l'incendie de sa
maison une voisine alertée par une forte
odeur de brûlée avec appelé les secours
qui se sont déplacés mais trop tard
une bâche désormais la maison au curieux
ou ce qu'il reste de la maison car tous
les tâches à brûlé hier matin causant la
mort du propriétaire des lieux qui
dormaient là quand les pompiers sont
intervenus il était trop tard bien trop
tard même et ce qui pose aujourd'hui
question le lendemain les journalistes
sont au courant qui aurait eu un quoique
entre guillemets aux pompiers
n'avaient pas été pris au sérieux donc
qui amène à penser que effectivement les
pompiers s'ils avaient réagi plutôt
aurait pu sauver Jean-Luc Lepage
tous les pensées que Jean-Jacques Lepage
est mort brûlé dans les flammes pour
déterminer les causes de cette incendie
le parquet de Brest décide d'ouvrir une
enquête
les gendarmes commencent par entendre
les proches de la victime et notamment
son fils
Pierre-Yves le PAL
on n'a pas d'informations particulières
sinon qu'il est décédé dans un incendie
et on me demande est-ce qu'il fumait oui
est-ce qu'il a pu s'endormir dans son
lit avec sa cigarette oui
la maison à brûler bon ben voilà
c'est un de 68 ans qui vivait seul dans
cette maison et qui était un gros fumeur
donc en un premier temps ils imaginent
qu'il a fumé au lit et que cette
cigarette a embrasé sa literie
seulement la thèse d'un possible
accident va très vite voler en éclat
les experts vont rendre leur travail
d'expertise en disant que c'est un
incendie criminel en tout cas que c'est
un incendie volontaire que ce n'est pas
un accident et que c'est pas un
court-circuit ou quelque chose comme ça
on a visiblement quelqu'un qui a
volontairement mille feux à cet endroit
l'incendie est donc criminel
alors en refusant d'intervenir tout de
suite les pompiers ont-ils condamné
Jean-Jacques Lepage c'est l'autopsie qui
va apporter la réponse à cette question
et là on se rend compte qu'il est
porteur de 15 coups de couteau notamment
et donc l'origine de la mort ne fait pas
beaucoup de doutes puisque ce serait
c'est 15 que de couteau qui aurait été
et donc absolument pas l'incendie
puisque a priori c'est poumons sont
entre guillemets propres et donc il n'a
pas il n'a pas une année de fumer
on retrouve également une blessure à
l'oeil provenant une décharge du terme à
grenaille c'est de la limaille de fer
qui vraiment est arrivé dans l'orbite
oculaire et puis surtout le corps il y a
des traces de limaille de fer
l'autopsie permet également de
déterminer l'heure de la mort elle se
situe entre 23h30
[Musique]
mais que s'est-il passé dans la nuit du
23 au 24 juillet 2009 dans cette ville
[Musique]
qui en voulait à Jean-Jacques Lepage
pour le tuer aussi violemment ce qui est
sûr c'est que l'existence de 15 coups de
couteau c'est un acharnement il y a
vraiment une volonté délibérée de donner
la mort quand on met 15 coups de couteau
c'est dans un état intense de stress et
de rage
pour Pierre-Yves Lepage qui pensait que
son père était mort dans un accident
l'annonce est terrible
tout d'un coup on nous apprend
qu'effectivement de façon assez solaire
solennelle et assez brutale qui est
décédé
suite à non pas l'incendie mais un
meurtre par un meuble blanche
et je me souviens très bien
je suis sorti du bureau
et je crois que j'ai jamais hurler comme
ça
[Musique]
les enquêteurs ont désormais un meurtre
à résoudre et très vite un élément
fondamental leur apparaît
en inspectant le rez-de-chaussée de la
villa épargné par les flammes il
constate que le retraité n'était pas
seul la nuit du meurtre les enquêteurs
découvrent sur une table une bouteille
de champagne vide et deux verres de
coupe à champagne et ce n'est pas tout
dans les toilettes dont la fenêtre est
restée ouverte les gendarmes font une
autre découverte de taille
ils vont découvrir l'empreinte d'une
chaussure d'une semelle de chaussures de
grande taille 44 sur la cuvette des
toilettes mais à qui appartient cette
empreinte pour le moment impossible de
le savoir mais une chose est sûre elle
ne correspond pas à la pointure de la
victime
[Musique]
en attendant et comme toujours en pareil
cas les gendarmes s'intéressent à la
personnalité de la victime qui était
elle avait-elle des ennemis
donc à la base il est opticien et il a
un peu galéré quand il s'est installé
financièrement donc en fait il s'est
vite mis dans la prothèse auditive et
c'est là où en fait il y avait à
l'époque peu d'audioprothésistes et donc
il a fait vraiment toute sa carrière là
dedans et il a très très bien réussi
c'est un homme toute façon qui était
charmeur brillant très intelligent il
avait un talent qui lui a servi
énormément et qui a contribué à sa
réussite professionnelle c'est qu'il
avait l'air quand vous êtes vous étiez
en face de lui de vous faire comprendre
que vous n'étiez pas non pas la personne
la plus importante pour lui mais la
personne la plus importante au monde
c'était pas quelqu'un qui était un grand
homme musclé beau surfeur etc mais
pourtant qui était assez séducteur en
particulier avec les dames
mais il y avait une ombre au tableau
Jean-Jacques Lepage a perdu sa femme
deux ans plus tôt et il se sentait
terriblement seul alors à 68 ans il
sortait régulièrement le soir à la
recherche de l'âme sœur souvent plus
jeune que lui Jean-Jacques Lepage était
quelqu'un qui
qui émet s'entourer de jeunes filles
participaient à des soirées sans
forcément qu'il y ait une connotation
sexuelle mais c'est quelqu'un qui qui
avait un souci de séduction il voulait
profiter notamment sur la fin de sa vie
de ces derniers instants de jeunesse il
fréquente un club à hôtesse le club 46
qui est un bar à bouchon c'est à dire le
principe est simple les clients viennent
pour trouver de la compagnie une
compagnie féminine et quand on dit à
bouchon c'est parce qu'il faut un
certain nombre de bouchons de champagne
enfin de bouteille de campagne ou de
coupe de champagne consommée pour avoir
le droit quelques faveurs de ces dames
qui se trouvent de l'autre côté du bar
au fil du temps et à force de fréquenter
ce bar à hôtesse Jean-Jacques Lepage est
parvenu à trouver l'amour une certaine
Lola 24 ans Laetitia Monnier de son vrai
nom mais solitaire il a envie
d'affection il a envie de tendresse et
de relations sexuelles et Laetitia
l'aime beaucoup parce que il est
extrêmement gentil il est extrêmement
raffiné il est respectueux c'est curieux
que ça puisse paraître voilà cet homme
de 68 ans qui a une vie honorable qui se
retrouve amoureuse d'une jeune fille de
24 ans petite vertu Jean-Jacques Lepage
semble heureux il nourrissait même avec
Laetitia un grand projet il va se tisser
entre les deux à un lien assez
extraordinaire au point que Monsieur
Lepage parlera d'épouser Laetitia il
avait l'intention de la demander en
mariage c'était quelque chose qu'on
savait on trouvait ça passablement
ridicule si vous voulez mais en même
temps vous voulez trop rien lui dire
puisqu'on voyait tellement heureux et ça
faisait tellement de temps qu'on l'avait
pas vu sourire
Lola semble sincère avec Jean-Jacques
Lepage elle l'apprécie et aime passer du
temps avec lui c'est en tout cas ce
qu'elle avait confié à sa maman
je connaissais depuis peu de temps
peut-être trois semaines je ne sais pas
et elle m'en avait dit du bien elle
avait dit qu'il avait
la différence d'âge Laetitia Monnier et
Jean-Jacques Lepage sont heureux
ensemble et cela intrigue les enquêteurs
alors ils vont fouiller dans la vie de
la jeune call-girl pour tenter de
découvrir si elle n'a pas quelques
secrets inavoués
[Musique]
d'abord
il découvre que Laetitia est arrivé en
Bretagne il y a peu de temps
visiblement elle tentait de fuir sa mère
justement avec laquelle elle entretenait
une relation fusionnelle
à l'époque des faits il faut bien
comprendre qu'elle pour la première fois
elle vit en autonomie c'est à dire que
elle a décidé de quitter Saint-Étienne
et par la même de quitter sa mère après
les venus sur Brest je sais pas ce que
on a pourquoi elle a choisi elle a
choisi Brest je ne sais pas bref c'est
un bout du monde
c'est à dire c'est l'endroit le plus
loin possible de Saint-Étienne comme par
hasard c'est là que vient Laetitia mais
sa mère va pas tarder à la rejoindre
parce que semble-t-il c'est
insupportable pour Chantal Monnier
d'être loin de sa fille
très vite Laetitia Monnier trouve du
travail à Brest dans ce fameux bar à
hôtesse où elle se fait appeler Lola et
Lola 24 ans a une spécificité
antisia Monier c'est une call-girl qui
est une particularité qui était
démontrée par la suite c'est qu'elle est
vierge
et donc elle a dit peut-être
peut-être qu'en regardant sa virginité
si quelqu'un l'aimait vraiment donc il
respecterait et il attendrait avant de
vouloir avoir une relation sexuelle avec
elle alors Jean-Jacques Lepage est-il
l'heureux élu avec lequel Lola est en
confiant
la jeune entraîneuse est-elle
sincèrement amoureuse de cet homme de
plus de 40 ans qu'elle
et puis était-elle avec lui le soir du
crime
les enquêteurs décident de l'entendre
sur la soirée du 23 juillet 2009
Laetitia Monier va très
spontanément reconnaître que
effectivement elle est en relation
fréquente avec la victime et que ce
jour-là ils se sont vus qu'ils ont dînés
ensemble aux Flunch
qu'ensuite ils sont allés chez lui pour
prendre un des consommations notamment
du champagne et qu'elle a quitté les
lieux vers 23h23h30 et qu'il était qu'il
était vivant
Laetitia Monnier affirme donc avoir
laissé Jean-Jacques Lepage vivant elle
explique avoir passé le reste de la nuit
dans une fête dans le même quartier
elle va rencontrer des jeunes qui ont
dans la maison de l'un d'eux finir la
soirée et elle va se faire embarquer par
ces jeunes qui lui proposent de venir à
la soie
seulement on vérifiant ces déclarations
les gendarmes vont découvrir que cette
nuit-là Laetitia Monnier n'est pas passé
inaperçue il retrouve un certain nombre
de participants à cette soirée qui
confirme la présence de Laetitia Monier
à partir de minuit en gros ni moins le
quart peut-être dans cette soirée
ce qui est certain c'est qu'elle est
très alcoolisée
elle a des comportements curieux mais
elle va semble-t-il rester discuter très
longtemps en buvant avec aussi un des
jeunes elle a même été rejoindre un
jeune homme qui était parti prendre une
douche et lui a proposé spontanément de
lui faire quelques caresses ce qu'il a
accepté et il y a autre chose le jeune
homme révèle que Laetitia Monnier
cachait un objet pour le moins
surprenant dans son sac à main ce jeune
homme entendu dira quelque chose
d'intéressant puisque elle avait posé
son sac sur un tabouret et que le sac
est tombé du tabouret et il est l'homme
a vu un couteau un couteau qui était
dans le sac à main un couteau qui
portait des traces rougeâtres précisera
même ce jeune homme
[Musique]
un peu plus tard dans la matinée du 24
juillet Laetitia sera aperçue sur la
plage juste au pied de la maison de
Jean-Jacques Lepage
et cela va pour le moins intriguer les
gens d'armes
elle va avoir un comportement qui va
étonner parce que elle est à la plage
elle est habillée elle s'expose en plein
soleil puis va se baigner tout habillé
on remarque que son comportement parce
que c'est pas une plagiste elle est pas
en maillot de bain avec sa serviette de
bain sa crème solaire etc on voit bien
que
dans peu curieux plusieurs personnes et
beaucoup un couteau dans son sac à main
c'est à dire que en fait sera vu le
manche du couteau dans son sac à main un
comportement étrange à proximité du
domicile de la victime un couteau en
sanglanté
tous les pensées que Laetitia Monier
serait impliquée dans le meurtre de
Jean-Jacques Lepage
[Musique]
les gendarmes ont bien compris qu'il y
avait un truc qui allaient pas et
qu'elle avait pas tout dit en tout cas
qu'elle allait certainement pas dit
toute la vérité
réentendu par les enquêteurs Laetitia
Monier va alors reconnaître qu'elle
était présente au moment du crime mais
qu'elle n'était pas seule
selon elle elle était accompagnée par un
certain William Rolland alors William
Rolland c'est c'est un jeune Brestois
c'est quelqu'un qui sonne un petit peu
peut-être que le terme de paumé serait
pas très très flatteur pour lui mais
c'est quelqu'un qui voit la kiki qui n'a
pas de travail il n'a pas des bonnes
fréquentations non plus et c'est
quelqu'un qui depuis deux trois semaines
avant les faits en tout cas et devenu
ami avec avec Laetitia Monnier
William Roland le voici et le jeune
homme l'avoue il avait des sentiments
pour Laetitia Monnier je l'ai rencontré
pour la première fois au bas de ma rue
elle se présente le nom de Marie
donc
une jeune femme de 20 ans
et donc qui m'a tout de suite avoué
depuis ton blanc que qu'elle travaillait
donc dans les bars alors moi j'avais
pour espoir en fait de devenir amis avec
plus si affinités
ça je ne l'ai jamais caché d'ailleurs
seulement pour William Rolland rien ne
va se passer comme il le prévoyait
[Musique]
car face aux enquêteurs Laetitia Monier
va largement mettre en cause le jeune
homme dans le meurtre de Jean-Jacques
Lepage
voici ce qu'elle raconte à propos de
ceux qui se seraient passés dans la
soirée du 23 juillet 2009
selon la jeune femme c'est un
cambriolage qui aurait mal tourné
monsieur Lepage aurait demandé à
Laetitia Monnier une prestation de
nature sexuelle il a été question de
prendre un main ensemble et la rémunérer
lorsque
le Badi est en train de couler que
Monsieur Lepage était occupé William
Rolland serait rentré dans la maison
selon le projet de cambriolage s'ils
avaient établi au départ et puis là où
il aime Roland fait du bruit et donc par
conséquent Jean-Jacques Lepage entend
il surprend
[Musique]
et là du coup et bien William Rolland
sous la menace physique à remonter
Jean-Jacques Lepage dans sa chambre
pendant que Laetitia Monnier restait au
rez-de-chaussée pour fouiller elle
aurait pris notamment 500 euros dans la
poche du manteau et après quel est
dérobée cet argent et l'entend à
hurlement à l'étage elle monte et là
elle assiste enfin elle voit au sol
Jean-Jacques Lepage mortellement touché
en tout cas il bouge plus il est mort et
c'est William Rolland qui l'a tué
va demander à Laetitia de partir de la
maison
et de quitter les lieux et là elle part
et elle ne le reverra plus selon donc sa
version
la version de Laetitia semble crédible
et immédiatement les enquêteurs se
lancent à la recherche de William
Rolland mais le jeune homme semble
s'être volatilisé
ils vont aller à son domicile il ne le
trouve pas donc par conséquent ils vont
le chercher un petit peu partout à moins
d'une coïncidence c'est vrai que ça
ressemble beaucoup à une fuite puis
comme il n'arrive vraiment pas à mettre
la main dessus ils vont le diffuser
comme on dit dans le dans le jargon
policier
c'est d'ailleurs qui vont lui décerner
un mandat de recherche
c'est à la faveur d'un incroyable
concours de circonstances que les
gendarmes vont retrouver William Rolland
à plus de 1200 km de Brest
le jeune homme étant fait en vacances à
Marseille et il se rend au commissariat
pour déclarer la perte de ses papiers
d'identité
en déclarant son identité évidemment le
policier qui est en face de lui tape son
nom et son prénom et là il faisait
l'objet d'un mandat de recherche donc le
policier lui dit ben Monsieur Roland
venait par ici et on vous garde que
quand ils ont vu mon nom Roland William
en rouge mandat d'arrêt
c'est là que ils ont commencé à me
regarder bizarrement
et puis hop trois ou quatre policiers se
sont mis autour de moi et
vraiment arrêté comme un gangster quoi
dans le dos et tout et
jaloux aucune idée du chef d'incubation
à ce moment-là je disais même l'officier
qu'est-ce qui se passe et il se retrouve
j'allais dire là à partir de ce
moment-là embarquait dans une histoire
qui va le complètement le dépasser
William Rolland est transféré à Brest et
confié aux enquêteurs qui travaillent
sur le meurtre de Jean-Jacques Lepage
à ce moment là le jeune homme ignore
tout de ce dont on l'accuse
pour moi j'étais un milieu de
savoir que c'était une histoire aussi
sordide qui allait me tomber dessus il
est placé au garde la vue dans la foulée
on lui dit
vous êtes accusés de meurtre et
d'incendie d'une maison à Plougonvelin
dans le Finistère je veux dire c'est le
ciel qui lui tombe sur la tête
puis les gendarmes lui annoncent qu'une
jeune femme Laetitia Monier l'implique
dans le meurtre de Jean-Jacques Lepage
je dis directement l'inspecteur
moi je n'ai rien à vous cacher je vais
tout vous dire parce que quand j'ai
appris le chef d'incubation pourquoi
j'étais là tous ces écroulé autour de
moi je me suis senti trahi
alors tout d'abord Julie je nie
totalement totalement j'étais persuadé
que ça pouvait être moi et personne
d'autre tout simplement parce que
j'étais allé sur Marseille à cette
époque là et pour eux ils ont fait le
lien ils ont dû se dire ah bah tiens il
a foutu le camp ça peut être que lui
ça s'arrête là
le jeune homme raconte alors aux
enquêteurs qu'il était bien avec
Laetitia Monnier le 23 juillet 2009 mais
voici selon lui comment ce serait
déroulée la journée
William Rolland passe une partie de
cette journée avec Laetitia Monnier et
Laetitia Monnier lui dit à un moment
donné qu'elle a rendez-vous au travail
avec un client
dont on connaît pas l'identité
on a comme un accord convenu de se
retrouver le soir le soir même donc à
mon appartement
donc pour un petit apéro un petit
apéritif et William raconte qu'il a
choisi ce moment-là pour avouer ses
sentiments à Laetitia
j'avais prévu un petit bouteille de
mousseux des cacahuètes des pistaches
tout ça pour qu'on soit qu'on se mette
bien quoi un petit apéritif en petits
comité tous les deux et puis je dois
être à l'aise seulement voilà Laetitia
se fait attendre
William Rolland en fait il passe la
soirée à attendre Laetitia Monnier
je lui ai envoyé des sms pour savoir ce
qu'elle faisait un peu elle m'a rappelé
et elle me dit je vais pas tarder
la jeune femme ne viendra jamais
dépité William Rollon passe la soirée en
ville avec l'un de ses amis il parle le
lendemain pour des vacances à Marseille
prévu depuis longtemps
[Musique]
mais la version du jeune homme ne va pas
convaincre les enquêteurs car certains
éléments les intriguent dans
perquisition les gendarmes ont découvert
une paire de chaussures de sport des
baskets qui sont de taille 44 et qui
colle à peu près avec l'empreinte
retrouvée sur la cuvette des toilettes
[Musique]
l'expert qui examine cette lunette
écrit un rapport dans lequel il indique
que cette trace de semelle qui figure
sur la lunette des toilettes peut
correspondre
à la chaussure de William Rolland mais
qu'il sera toujours impossible de dire
que c'est la trace de la chaussure de
William Rolland et c'est toute
l'ambiguïté de la conclusion ça peut
correspondre à sa chaussure mais on ne
pourra pas dire que c'est ça
et ce n'est pas tout William Rolland a
des marques sur le corps
des marques qui ont tout de suite attiré
l'attention des enquêteurs
et là au visage et un peu partout sur le
dos et au niveau des des avant-bras des
traces de brûlures traces de brûlure qui
ont été vus par un médecin légiste qui
considère qu'elles sont compatibles avec
quelqu'un qui a été au contact d'un
incendie ça leur paraît tout de suite
suspect de voir les traces sur mon corps
j'avais une chute en skateboard il y a
deux ou trois mois de ça ça n'avait rien
à voir avec cette histoire de meurtre en
fait
malgré ces dénégations les enquêteurs
sont persuadés de détenir un coupable
alors ils vont tout mettre en œuvre pour
le faire avouer
durant cette garde à vue il va subir
plus de 12 heures d'interrogatoire sur
de mémoire 4 interrogatoires les trois
premiers il va se battre j'allais dire
bec et ongles en disant qu'il n'a
absolument rien fait
mais comme cela se produit parfois au 4e
interrogatoire William Roland est à bout
de nerf et finit par craquer
je suis tombé au larmes je pour moi
j'étais totalement humilié j'étais je me
sentais souillée je j'en avais assez je
voulais que ça se termine j'ai pensé à
ma famille
à mon avenir à ce pauvre
vieil homme qui s'est fait assassiner
d'une façon sordide
il avait été pris d'une telle angoisse
que la seule façon de sortir de cette
fameuse angoisse c'était de procéder à
des aveugles il va expliquer que il est
le complice de Laetitia Monnier dans son
idée de cambriolage ou en tout cas de de
vol par ruse donc pendant qu'elle est
dans la baignoire avec Jean-Jacques
Lepage son boulot à lui c'était de
cambrioler en fait la maison et les
choses se sont mal passées donc ils
reconnaît le meurtre et il reconnaît
également l'incendie
seulement très vite après ses aveux
William Rolland regrette et se rétracte
et il va d'ailleurs le faire savoir au
plus haut niveau
il va écrire au juge d'instruction et
courrier dans lequel il va expliquer
qu'il a fait des avatars que il a été il
a subi une pression à vue et que il
était en rien à Plougonvelin ce soir-là
et qu'il n'a jamais tué qui que ce soit
je crois de mémoire d'ailleurs il disait
qu'il en était bien incapable je reviens
sur mes aveux car clairement pour moi il
y avait un justice là-dessus voici ce
que va écrire William au juge j'étais
affaibli mentalement et physiquement
j'aurais tout fait pour que ce cauchemar
s’arrête je n'ai jamais tué personne
j'en suis pas capable mais il y a
quelque chose qui cloche et qui peut
remettre en cause la sincérité des
rétractations de William Rolland
si le jeune homme est innocent comment
connaissait-il les détails du meurtre et
s'il n'était pas à plus gonvelin ce
soir-là comment a-t-il pu raconter le
même scénario que Laetitia Monnier
il y a peut-être une explication que
donne son avocat ce sont les enquêteurs
qui au fil des interrogatoires on peut
même livrer les circonstances du meurtre
l'enquêteur lui avait montré un certain
nombre de photos de la scène de crime
extérieur de la maison donc
effectivement William Rolland lorsqu'il
passe aux aveux n'a fait en fait que
restituer ce qu'il avait entendu et vu
puisque l'enquêteur lui avait lu
également une partie des dépositions de
Laetitia Bonnier
malgré tout rien n'y fait William
Rolland et Laetitia Monnier sont tous
les deux mises en examen pour le meurtre
de Jean-Jacques Lepage ils sont placés
en détention provisoire à la prison de
Brest
mais l'avocat du jeune homme continue de
se battre et c'est grâce à des photos de
famille qu'il va réussir à prouver que
son client est peut-être innocent car
les traces que les gendarmes prennent
pour des brûlures ne sont en réalité que
les conséquences d'une chute
il m'a dit mais avant de partir à
Marseille bien avant c'est cette affaire
là j'étais allé chez ma mère pour
l'anniversaire de d'une sœur ou d'une
cousine et il avait fait du il avait
fait du skateboard et il était tombé et
donc il avait des blessures et donc il y
avait des photos qui avaient été prises
à l'époque on les a communiqué au juge
d'instruction les blessures préexister à
toute cette affaire donc c'est un petit
peu affaibli ce cet élément d'accusation
quand même
où William Rolland est alors remis en
liberté sous contrôle judiciaire après
deux mois et 10 jours de détention alors
si ce n'est pas lui qui a tué
Jean-Jacques Lepage
qui est-ce
un an après le meurtre Laetitia Monnier
est à nouveau entendu la jeune femme a
des révélations à faire et le moins que
l'on puisse dire c'est que ça nouvelle
version de l'histoire paraît encore plus
un vrai semblable que les précédents
elle va donner une autre version en
faisant intervenir à 3e personnage
monsieur Habib alors Habib pour elle
c'est un ami également un ami avec
autant de guillemets possible un ami
autant que là William Rolland c'est à
dire pas vraiment un ami finalement
c'est quelqu'un qui traîne quelqu'un qui
sonne dans Brest pas quelqu'un qui
repose ton plus sur des bases
intégration sociale solide les gendarmes
vont vérifier l'emploi du temps de ce
garçon Habib et s'apercevoir assez
rapidement qu'il ne pouvait pas être sur
les lieux du crime à l'heure du crime le
jour du crime il a un ennemi comme on
dit en béton et par conséquent la piste
va être écartée assez rapidement mais en
tout cas c'est un des derniers
soubresauts de Laetitia Monnier dans son
système de défense
quelques semaines plus tard nouveau
rebondissements une lettre anonyme
arrive sur le bureau de la juge
d'instruction
[Musique]
une lettre
qui dit voilà je en gros alors en
substance je sais où sont les couteaux
qui ont servi au meurtre de Jean-Jacques
Le Pen
cette lettre va décrire le chemin à
parcourir pour arriver jusqu'à une
cachette dans un mur ou de fait les
enquêteurs vous retrouvez un sac qui
ressemble terriblement au descriptions
qui sont faites par rapport au sac qui
avait Laetitia manier le soir des faits
et puis de couteau
[Musique]
cette découverte ne va rien donner
puisqu'en fait on ne retrouve pas de
trace de sang sur ces couteaux on a
aucun élément de preuve comme quoi il
s'agirait des armes du crime
[Musique]
la juge d'instruction ordonne alors une
analyse graphologique de la lettre pour
en découvrir l'auteur
et les résultats de cette expertise sont
pour le moins étonnants
[Musique]
elle aurait été écrite par un certain
abiber Habib aurait-il voulu se venger
de Laetitia Monnier qui l'avait
injustement accusé du crime
peut-être bien
il est interrogé sur ce point et il dira
que ce possible que ce soit lui s'en
souvient pas très bien parce qu'il
picole beaucoup et quand il picole il se
souvient pas de ce qu'il fait mais qu'il
est très en colère contre Laetitia
Monier de l'avoir dénoncé et que ça
pourrait être une vengeance
mais si ni William Rolland ni Habib ne
sont les auteurs du crime qui a tué
Jean-Jacques Lepage
la jeune femme aurait-elle agisse seule
[Musique]
difficile de le savoir
mais pour l'avocat de la famille Lepage
plusieurs détails mettent en cause
Laetitia Monnier
elle va prendre une douche
quelques heures après les faits avec un
des jeunes garçons elle va aller dans la
piscine tout habillé le lendemain
lorsqu'elle va se retrouver sur la plage
du trezir elle va retourner se baigner
comme si
elle voulait se laver de ce qu'elle
avait pu commettre cette volonté de
pureté qu'on retrouve dans la volonté de
préservation de sa virginité et pour moi
aussi un des indices un des faisceaux
d'indices qui nous ramène au rôle
central de Laetitia Monnier dans la
Commission du crime seulement un
faisceau d'indices cela ne suffit pas je
ne vois pas de mobile au fait que
Laetitia Monnier est plus tuer
Jean-Jacques Lepage
elle l'aimait bien il était généreux qui
voulait l'épouser pourquoi voulez-vous
qu'elle le tue elle avait pas de raison
de le tuer elle aurait quoi elle aurait
pu avec les couteaux et des bas mais ça
a pas de sens c'est criminel ça c'est
les terroristes qui vont avec des
couteaux et des armes là c'est pas
possible
je parle même pas du fait soigneusement
occulter mais qui est quand même
absolument réel qui fait que Monsieur
Lepage a du plomb dans l'oeil il a reçu
un coup de pistolet à grenaille dans
l'oeil pistolet qu'on a pas retrouvé et
on se demande bien ce que Laetitia
aurait fait avec
et si Laetitia utilisait un pistolet et
un couteau pour tuer monsieur Lepage
pourquoi c'est elle débarrassé du
pistolet et a-t-elle précieusement gardé
un couteau qui serait soi-disant couvert
de sang ça paraît totalement absurde
tout état de cause les armes du crime ne
seront jamais retrouvés
il y a un autre argument qui tente
approuver que Laetitia ne peut pas être
l'auteur du crime c'est l'heure de
l'incendie comment voulez-vous que
l'incendie était allumée par Laetitia
monite sachant qu'elle est depuis
23h45 ou 23h30 dans une autre maison
dans une soirée avec d'autres gens et de
toute façon elle était dans un état tel
qu'elle s'est endormie et réveillée le
lendemain donc il y a quelqu'un à 5h du
matin dans la maison de Monsieur Lepage
ça ne fait aucun doute et ça ne fait
aucun doute non plus que ce quelqu'un
n'est pas Laetitia Monier
mais qui aurait incendié la maison
Laetitia Monnier aurait-elle eu un autre
complice quelqu'un qu'elle n'aurait
jamais dénoncé
ou pourrait-il s'agir de William Rolland
en tout cas le jeune homme bien que
libre reste mis en examen pour le
meurtre du retraité
sur la mort de Jean-Jacques Lepage va
durer 8 années 18 ans d'instruction
c'est un long sens une bonne instruction
ça dure un mois un an et demi deux ans
maximum et là le fait qu'il dure 8 ans
c'est quand même un mauvais présage
pourquoi c'est instruction a été très
longue principalement
du fait des systèmes de défense qui ont
été adoptés par par Laetitia Monnier à
savoir de conduire au moins à trois
reprises les enquêteurs sur des fausses
pistes ce qui a retardé bien évidemment
la clôture de l'instruction et qui a
donné à cette instruction une dimension
surréaliste elle a une personnalité très
particulière personnalité qui a été
qualifiée de plastique et c'est vraiment
ça elle s'adapte toujours à son
interlocuteur
si vous l'interrogez sur un thème et
qu'elle pense que vous souhaitez une
réponse elle va vous donner cette
réponse dixième année d'une suspecte
complexe parce qu'elle dit tout et son
contraire qu'elle donne 14 versions
différentes qu'elle désigne des gens qui
s'avèrent être innocents qu'elle dit pas
toute la vérité
pour William Rolland qui crie toujours
son innocence c'est huit ans
d'instruction ont été particulièrement
difficiles à vivre la longueur de de
cette instruction a été j'allais dire
hautement préjudiciable pour ce garçon
je sais pas si on peut s'imaginer de
entre guillemets traîner une accusation
d'assassinat pendant 8 années
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
difficile pour tout à chacun et je veux
dire que compte tenu la personnalité
fragile de William Rolland ça a été
extrêmement difficile à supporter ça a
été 8 ans de chaos ça a été huit ans de
descente aux enfers
où j'avais perdu tous mes repères
pour moi ça m'a inventé ça m'a hanté le
fait
que j'étais incertain de l'issue que ça
allait prendre au vu des éléments portés
à charge contre moi
le procès de Laetitia Monier et de
William Rolland s’ouvre le premier mars
2017 au tribunal de Quimper tout l'enjeu
sera de déterminer exactement ce qui
s'est passé ce 23 juillet 2009 dans la
villa de Jean-Jacques Lepage hier le
procès d'une call-girl brestoise et d'un
homme s'est ouvert huit ans après le
meurtre à Poulou gonvelin d'un retraité
de 67 ans
pour la famille de la victime ce procès
est une nouvelle plongée dans l'horreur
c'est un boomerang en fait qu'on a lancé
en 2009 et qui va revenir et il revient
en 2017 c'est 8 ans plus tard vous vous
avez enterré une cérébralement cette
affaire et là elle va revenir et puis
elle va revenir fort j'avais jamais vu
Laetitia Monnier
même pas une photo
[Musique]
je suis pas rentré dans le dans les
détails des procédures je l'entends
qu'elle a déjà donné 14 versions dans le
procès
maintenant est-ce que ce soit un petit
peu compliqué
quand on arrive aux assises au bout de 9
ans ce qu'on se dit c'est qu'on veut
avoir une vérité on s'en contrat de
cette vérité qu'on puisse refermer le
livre
pour William Rollon qui comparait libre
le moment est capital il s'agit de
démontrer qu'il est bel et bien innocent
je parle dans un esprit combatif inscrit
combatif mais tout de même la crainte
d'avoir cette épée de Damoclès on se
rend pas compte de ce que c'est une
salle d'assistant qu'on n'est pas
placé en tant qu'accus à la barre le
jeune homme se retrouve sur le bon des
accusés aux côtés de Laetitia Monnier
cette femme qui a fait basculer sa vie
dans l'horreur huit ans plus tôt c'est
la première fois qu'il la revoit je
ressens un énorme mélange de haine et de
pitié
nos regards se sont croisés
quelquefois et souvent elle baissait la
tête
comme si voilà elles se sentait coupable
d'avoir fait
une bêtise
dès les premières audiences l'avocat de
William Rolland veut démontrer que son
client ne pouvait tout simplement pas
être à la maison de Jean-Jacques Lepage
le soir du crime
souvenez-vous le jeune homme ce soir-là
est chez lui à Brest et attend Laetitia
ne la voyons pas venir il l'appellera
plusieurs reprises
le dernier appel
de William Rolland se situe à 22h30 il
est situé à Brest il y avait un autre
élément objectif qui était le voisin qui
était venu chercher William Rolland aux
alentours de minuit donc il y avait un
créneau horaire d'une heure et demie ça
serait le créneau horaire pendant lequel
le Jean-Jacques global aurait été tué la
seule solution qui se présentait à
William Rolland pour aller là-bas
c'était de faire du stop puisque il
n'avait pas ni son permis de conduire il
n'avait pas de moyen de locomotion
alors comment expliquer qu'en une heure
et demie et on stoppe William Rolland
est pu aller de Brest à Plougonvelin tu
es Jean-Jacques Lepage
et revenir à Brest en sachant qu'à
l'époque les gendarmes avaient eux-mêmes
calculé que cette allée retour prenait à
minima une heure
il lui restait un créneau de 7 minutes
pour rentrer dans la maison tu es
Jean-Jacques Lepage
mettre le feu à sa maison et ressortir
pour vous dire que c'était
matériellement impossible
j'avais clairement l'espoir d'être
innocenté au final et à part dire que
j'ai été innocent je qu'est-ce que je
pouvais leur dire de plus
[Musique]
souhaitait pas qu'elle ne voulait pas
puisqu'on a vu qu'elle voulait garder sa
virginité pour l'homme de sa vie donc
visiblement elle est considérée que
Jean-Jacques Lepage n'était pas l'homme
de sa vie
et à ce moment-là les choses auraient
mal tourné dans un moment de panique et
ensuite elle s'organise comme elle peut
elle vole ce qu'elle trouve et après
elle appelle quelqu'un pour venir mettre
le feu à 5h du matin ça c'est une
hypothèse tout à fait tout à fait
plausible mais alors qui serait ce
fameux complice et pourquoi la jeune
femme le protège-t-elle en accusant un
peu n'importe qui
[Musique]
elle protège probablement quelqu'un mais
elle veut pas de elle veut pas le
dénoncer et c'est souvent d'ailleurs
dans les dossiers criminels on
s'aperçoit que quand on commence à
dénoncer des gens qui sont innocents
c'est parce qu'on veut vraiment couvrir
quelqu'un de proche et qu'on ne dira
jamais qui est cette personne proche
et parmi les proches il y en a une qui
est au cœur des interrogations
ces Chantal Monnier la mère de Laetitia
on a découvert que cette dame avait pu
avoir
un rôle peut-être plus important que ce
qu'on avait imaginé malheureusement elle
était cité en tant que témoin en effet
l'enquête montre que Chantal Monnier
était près de chez Jean-Jacques Lepage
le 24 juillet 2009 à 9h du matin le
lendemain je suis allée au Conquet me
promener et ils ont dit j'étais pas loin
il fallait bien qu'il trouve il leur
faut chercher des des coupables comment
se fait-il
que
le lendemain des faits son téléphone
born à quelques centaines de mètres je
crois que c'est un kilomètre un
kilomètre 5 le matin
du domicile de Jean-Jacques Lepage je
lui ai posé la question
je n'ai pas eu de réponse
l'enquête a démontré qu'il existe des
zones d'ombre dans l'emploi du temps de
Chantal Monnier mais pour autant peut-on
imaginer que la mer et la fille soient
complice impossible à dire
cependant lorsque les avocats de la
partie civile vont demander à Laetitia
si sa mère l'a aidé à commettre le crime
la jeune femme d'habitude si bavarde va
bizarrement se taire pendant plusieurs
secondes
pendant 30 secondes il y a eu un silence
total dans la pièce on aurait entendu
une mouche passée ou un ange
et
où on s'est dit ça y est c'est là elle
va le dire
[Musique]
mais elle a failli on le sait tous elle
a eu 30 secondes de doute
où elle s'est dit je vais le dire la
vérité
[Musique]
après selon si l'on lance Laetitia
Monnier innocentra sa mère
définitivement
[Musique]
après 9 jours de procès le verdict tombe
William Rolland est acquitté il est
reconnu innocent du meurtre de
Jean-Jacques Lepage pour moi c'est
vraiment la chape de plomb qui a sauté
je me suis senti léger flottant vraiment
comme débarrassé
de tout le tout le poids de la
culpabilité qui avait pu pesé sur moi
c'est pas en vain que j'ai pu me battre
en fait quoi
finalement c'est son histoire qui était
la plus intéressante comment on peut
être accusé de meurtre pendant 8 ans
alors qu'il apparaissait évident que ce
type là n'avait n'avait rien fait pour
William Rolland c'est la fin de huit ans
de soupçon et de lutte il est enfin
libre de reprendre normalement sa vie
malgré l'absence de preuve formelle
Laetitia Monnier est-elle condamnée à 20
ans de réclusion criminelle pour le
meurtre de Jean-Jacques Lepage
[Musique]
bien évidemment la fait appel
immédiatement puisque elle ce qu'elle
veut c'est être acquitté et puis elle ne
veut rien d'autre
donc concrètement ça veut dire qu'il y
aura un nouveau procès sans William
Rolland cette fois-ci
ce qui n'est peut-être pas une mauvaise
chose puisque ça permettra de se
concentrer sur le cas particulier de
Laetitia Monnier et sur l'absence totale
de preuve s'agissant de Laetitia manier
elle est innocente donc il faut quand
même pas qu'on arrête d'accuser les
innocents et qui te en espérant qu'ils
vont trouver les le ou les coupables
mais même si les trouvait pas
qu'on a que qu'on la reconnaisse
innocente
voilà
pour la famille Lepage le procès en
appel s'annonce déjà comme une nouvelle
épreuve
psychologiquement je préfère que
l'affaire s'arrête là parce qu'on va
tout remettre à plat à nouveau mais
attendez dans ce cas là l'instruction
s'arrêtera quand on sera encore vivant
la vérité à 90% oh là
bon on va se contenter des 90%
c'est tout les 10% qui manquaient on a
failli les avoir on les aura plus
c'est tout
l'essentiel c'est que
la personne qui a porté les coûts la
personne qui a fait cet acte de barbarie
peu importe les détails de cet acte
qu'elle soit condamnées et qu'on nous
dise voilà maintenant retourner chez
vous vous pourrez retournez chez vous
lamenter parce que c'est un peu ça là
m'en vais
dans l'attente de son nouveau procès
Laetitia Monnier reste présumée
innocentes